le cuento que las regiones del sur se
encuentran en tensa calma precisamente a
la expectativa por lo que vaya a ocurrir
hoy en Lima en la denominada toma de
Lima como es denominada esta jornada de
protesta en la capital peruana en el sur
del Perú los bloqueos continúan
precisamente acá en puquio los
pobladores desobedecen la orden de la
presidenta Dina boluarte quien les pidió
les exigió que le vieraran las vías para
que transite los vehículos ellos me
dicen que no van a obedecer porque no
consideran presidenta a la actual
mandataria de este país y precisamente
la superintendencia de transportes ha
revelado que en la jornada hay ciento
seis puntos de tránsito interrumpidos
veintiún vidas nacionales afectadas y
doce regiones impactadas en todo
territorio peruano con estos bloqueos
los pobladores de puquio me han señalado
también que los bloqueos van a
permanecer hasta que no se cumplan las
exigencias que ellos han hecho que es la
renuncia de la presidenta Dina boluarte
el del Congreso y la convocatoria a
nuevas elecciones en este 2023